here we are at the end of 2017 we've
seen some terrible films as usual some
really good films but this has been
overall a pretty good year for film one
of the best in recent memory there's
been some real stinkers which we'll talk
about in the worst of the year video but
this was actually a really hard list to
make and I have a lot of honorable
mentions which I have tried to hone down
in the past or just a few this year
there are just some films that didn't
quite make my list that have to be
mentioned like all the money in the
world brawl in cellblock 99 Wonder Woman
call me by your name stronger the big
sick the last Jedi mother get out John
wick too and a silent voice 2017 had a
lot of great films but a lot of very
polarizing ones as well like the last
Jedi or mother fans are divided on both
of those films some think it's a
masterpiece some think it's the worst
film they've ever seen ever that's one
of the most beautiful things about film
though is that the opinions are going to
be varying we're not all robots we can
all think and act differently which is
why the next 15 films are going to be
different for myself than probably for
you
I chose 15 because there are just too
many this year that I did not want to
leave off this list so let's get started
with number 15 good time directed by the
safty brothers was much more than a good
time it was a great time that was a
horrible pun and I'm gonna go jump off a
cliff that being said I had a really
great time watching this film
I thought the direction was gorgeous I
thought it had Robert Pattinson s best
performance and it was also a very
ballsy movie a lot of things that happen
in this film many directors especially
quite famous directors and writers would
not even think of doing that's one of
the reasons why I have a lot of respect
for the safty brothers for making a film
that is quite subversive and different
and extremely thrilling
oh hi great movie
hahaha the disaster artist was
everything I wanted it to be and more I
was expecting a movie that was in the
know about the hilarity that is the room
but what I got was a surprisingly
heartfelt film about friendship and
tried to make it in the film industry it
has one of the best performances of the
year in James Franco's Tommy Weis oh
it's definitely worth checking out even
if you're not a huge fan of the room I
feel like each year Mike Flanagan makes
a great film and each year Mike Flanagan
makes a great film that people don't
talk about enough Gerald's game is one
of the best Stephen King adaptations
ever made one of the very few that I
think might be better than the book
itself this is also quite an achievement
for Carlo juji know who gives one of the
best performances I've seen all year the
film made my stomach churn at many
moments and it was surprisingly powerful
emotionally as well it told a really
great story that I wasn't expecting it
wasn't just about a woman in handcuffs
chained to a bed and oh my god what do I
do
it goes through her past life quite
effectively and it's on Netflix so check
this one out
[Music]
baby driver was one of the most
fast-paced films of the year definitely
not slow despite the song that has
become famous
ever since the film's release was he
slow Edgar Wright has consistently made
good two great films and baby driver is
just another one in his filmography that
is very much so worthy of being included
in the rest
[Music]
three billboards outside Epping Missouri
wasn't just the most uniquely titled
film of the year it was also one of the
most unique films of the year Frances
McDorman gives maybe her best
performance ever it's a film that pulls
no punches when it comes to dialogue
that could be off-putting for some it
dares to have arcs for horrible
characters in which they could possibly
be redeemed which is also a little hard
to come by in film it was gorgeously
shot compellingly acted filled with
powerful scenes and it was also a lot
funnier than I expected it to be
definitely check this one out if you
didn't get to see it when it was in
theaters similar to three billboards
I've never seen a film like a ghost
story in the way it was shot the way it
was edited the performances by Rooney
Mara the extremely long pie-eating scene
the film is just begging to be disliked
by most people and yet it was one of the
most fulfilling experiences that I had
at a theater this year I found this
movie extremely touching it also has one
of the best endings and songs featured
in that ending of the entire year I
highly suggest checking this one out if
you missed it
[Music]
Molly's game continues Aaron Sorkin's
streak a fantastic writing and
introduces us to him as a very competent
director Jessica Chastain as usual was
terrific in a film that was extremely
hard to believe despite being a true
story and consistently compelling from
beginning to end
[Music]
Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk will go down
in history perhaps not as the best
character-driven war film but one of the
best technically told war films ever put
to screen every scene in Dunkirk is
masterfully helmed the action sequences
and all of the performances there within
the camerawork and Hans Zimmer's score
all combined to make one of the most
thrilling experiences of the year and it
was one of the few films I got to see an
actual 70 millimeter this year which was
quite an experience wind river was one
of the biggest surprises for me in 2017
Jeremy Renner gave the best performance
I've ever seen from him Elizabeth Olsen
also fantastic Taylor Sheridan as usual
another great film out of this guy Logan
was the Wolverine film I have wanted for
as long as I can remember it was
everything I wanted it to be and more it
surprised me it took me off-guard
it had graphic violence in harsh
language and one of Hugh Jackman's best
performances james mangold as I said in
my review of the Wolverine is a
fantastic director the problems that the
Wolverine had I saw the potential for
greatness
I loved the Wolverine except for the
last 20 minutes and with Logan he takes
that potential and blows it through the
roof it's one of the best action films
I've seen in years and it pulls off an
astonishing feat despite the fact that
we have seen some really good comic-book
movies and an endless string of them
since the early 2000s Logan is one of
the best
[Music]
M night Shyamalan returned to form with
splits and gave us one of the best
performances of the year James McAvoy
has 24 different people this performance
is still being talked about but not as
much as it should be it should be an
Oscar contender but it probably won't be
it has an ending that makes the rest of
the film even better but I loved it
before that ending it was so nice to sit
in the theater in 2017 even though I saw
this originally back in 2016 at the AFI
Fest I saw it again in January and it
was just so nice to be sitting in a
theater seeing a great M night Shyamalan
film say what you want to about this
film in regards to the Thor cannon it's
the third film the first two were fairly
serious this one was basically a comedy
and all the better for thor ragnarok was
one of the most fun experiences I've had
at the theaters all year I saw it twice
in one weekend the second time I wasn't
bored for a minute it has one of my
favorite finales of 2017 with the Led
Zepplin immigrant song bursting into
this film it was just such an exciting
experience it felt like watching a
Saturday morning cartoon from the 80s
blown up on the big screen and in
regards to Marvel movies I've enjoyed
quite a bit of them I think they've done
some really good things but this might
be my favorite for pure fun it's not the
best Marvel movie but in regards to just
pure unadulterated fun Ragnarok
delivered on every front and it gave me
Korg which I never knew I wanted
[Music]
war for the Planet of the Apes is a film
that has divided some fans some really
enjoyed it critics seem to really dig it
but there are a lot of people that found
it boring the fact that it's called war
and there's really just kind of a battle
in it to me the film was more about a
psychological war yeah there's a battle
in the film and it's not so much about a
bunch of guns and explosions it's about
these two groups of people Caesar and
his Apes and the humans and the turmoil
that has gone on for ages between the
two from the beginning to the end of the
film there wasn't a moment that bored me
and I was blown away by the technical
mastery presented by Matt Reeves and
Andy Serkis and his motion capture team
Steve Zahn was also really good in a
role that could have been quite annoying
but really paid off this is my favorite
film in the apes trilogy for some that
might not be true just from a
screenwriting perspective the fact that
there's basically just one big
exposition scene that the rest of the
film is mostly straightforward visual
storytelling I found that astounding
[Music]
Greta Gerwig Staib you with Lady Bird is
one of the most impressive debuts I've
ever seen this film was so pure and real
and just true it just felt like I wasn't
watching a movie like I was somehow
watching these recorded scenes from a
documentary just presented really
beautifully sheersha ronan gave an
amazing performance really everyone in
the film was fantastic but what was so
great about Lady Bird is the fact that
it just left off the screen and reminded
me of moments that I've had in my life I
feel like just about anybody can watch
this movie and be like yeah I relate to
that in some way shape or form it's so
rare that I see a film where when I
leave I feel like I've just felt
something like it's really impacted me I
Drive home from the theater thinking
about the beauty of the film and Lady
Bird is one of those movies all right
guys it's come down to that time to talk
about my favorite film of 2017 the film
that didn't disappoint me in any way a
film that I feel is a complete technical
masterpiece and that film is
[Music]
it took me a long time to appreciate the
original Blade Runner it was a film that
was far more adult and mature than I
expected it to be when I first watched
it so I was pretty terrified about Blade
Runner 2049 because this year I really
came to love the fairs of Blade Runner I
rewatched it again and man that is such
a masterpiece so walking in the 2049 I
was pretty scared and I left thinking
that might have been better than the
original this is the second year in a
row that Ryan Gosling has been in my
favorite film of the year the man
continues to choose incredible scripts
and works with some of the best people
Denis Villeneuve directed this film and
man him combined with Roger Deakins was
one of the most i gasps mick expirience
--is in 2017
Harrison Ford gave one of his best
performances he did not sleepwalk
through this movie at all he was
terrific as Deckard and the film
maintains a lot of the mysteries that
Blade Runner did regards to his
character which I loved man what a
beautiful movie one of the best science
fiction films I've seen in so long and
Blade Runner 2049 is my favorite film of
the year guys thank you for experiencing
another year in film with me it has been
quite the ride I had a great time
talking about movies with you this year
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to my worst of the year
list coming soon oh I'm already dreading
it guys thank you so much as always and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]